a lot about the school of life happens
digitally on our YouTube channel on our
app and on our website but every now and
then we like to gather together
physically on a big scale in order to
meet face to face learn together and
make new friends on the 20th of October
we're going to be hosting a large
conference in one of the most stunning
and inviting cities of Europe Lisbon in
Portugal it's going to be a conference
about everything we care about emotional
intelligence wisdom self understanding a
grasp of relationships of work and of
our higher purpose and meaning people
will be coming to our conference from
all over the world
we'll have lectures in the day great
meals together tours around beautiful
historic Lisbon and chats about pretty
much everything that matters late into
the night it'll be a true chance to
build globally minded community
dedicated to learning kindness self
exploration and wisdom the conference
will last three days it'll be led by our
founder and creative lead and under
bottle and we'll feature our best
teachers and our very best and most
transformative ideas if you're
interested in coming to Portugal in
October to meet us please click on the
link on the screen now you'll learn a
lot and not least the weather should be
beautiful and barmy we hope to see you
there